Adrian will Generale ski SPN senior NBA
insider joining us where are you right
now Adrian I'm in Vegas then where else
would I be doing better
what what are you they are placing a bet
or something are you watching the G
League wait why are you in Vegas I am
watching the G League he had a ladder
the ladder yep
oh okay is there when will we have an
NBA team well we have an NBA team in
Vegas or Seattle first a good question I
think the league is well past their
concerns about Vegas that existed years
ago I think there's a I think there's a
sense around the league that Seattle
deserves a team they deserve a team back
but a lot there would depend on or on
the arena and also what teams are moving
and it's not unlike the NFL you know NBA
teams don't the league is much they try
to keep teams in places you see more
move in the NFL so we're not at the
point right now where a you have a
league that wants to expand and have
expansion teams they're not there and
right now you don't have any teams that
are really in the position to move so I
think it's gonna be years at years and
years I think before there's a Seattle
Vegas any of these places end up with a
team the only thing I thought was when
the sun's owner was threatening to move
that team he since you know walk that
back there but it needs everybody
financially sound all these NBA teams
yeah I think you know some markets that
you know you hear whether it's New
Orleans Memphis
I think there's local ownership in those
places that are committed to staying
where they are Phoenix is a great NBA
market historic NBA market they've been
mismanaged into you know irrelevance in
the league but there's nobody who thinks
that like hey you have to take a team
out of there that would be an arena play
for the owner and I think the league I
do think the league would push back on
that I don't think they want to leave
that market it's it's been too
successful you know over you know the
long belong
for them big shocker LeBron said that he
would love to play with Anthony Davis in
yeah then all of a sudden the ESPN echo
chamber started and here we go you know
this is this is front page here that the
Lakers won Anthony Davis all right the
likelihood of this happening how can the
Lakers make this happen and beat Boston
to the punch
they they probably have to break into
pelicans front office get into the
computer system and you know and create
a trade that doesn't exist New Orleans
is not trading him before the trade
deadline well I to me is I mean never
say never but there's no indication that
the pelicans you know would even
consider that before the trade deadline
now after the season it's possible if
Davis tells them hey I don't I'm not
going to sign my five-year 239 million
dollar Supermax extension this summer
which is typically now when euro you're
out of free agency in and of itself it
almost becomes a trade request because
you're telling the team you're rolling
the dice that you're going to lose me
for nothing next year and typically if
you were going to trade an Anthony Davis
you'd want to do it around the draft if
you were getting pics from a team in
that draft you want to be able to select
the players and you know you mentioned
in the intro that you know the idea that
you know they can't Boston because they
have the Supermax off deal with Kyrie
Irving you know they can't have two guys
on it and so at the same time but you
could agree in principle to a deal
around the draft and not execute it till
after July 1 if you wanted to get at
Boston's picks this year but right now
the pelicans are still trying to do
deals to improve the team around Davis
they bet they've had a lot of injuries I
think they think when they're healthy
you know they're a middle tier Western
Conference contender in a group with a
bunch of other teams now is that enough
for Anthony Davis that you know that
remains to be seen but if I look at and
I've pleaded with the Lakers publicly to
have patients let these kids develop let
them learn how to play with LeBron be
around that circus that is LeBron but
you know it feels like you know magic is
such a competitor that he you know hey I
want to make this team great and and I
just feel like they may cash in some of
these kids they're the chips with these
kids you know I don't know if Ingram it
feels like Ingram doesn't really fit
here I don't know if ball fits there as
well
like what can you give up that's going
to be interesting here if you were able
to put a trade together what would what
would pique the pelicans interest with
the Lakers everything everything because
Boston and the other teams listen
there'll be other teams out there
because it's Anthony Davis you know like
you saw with Jimmy Butler I'm not
comparing their impact but there were
teams even there were teams who didn't
have a promise that Jimmy Butler would
resign with them who are willing to
trade for him with a year left on his
deal the way Toronto did with Kawhi
Leonard the way Oklahoma City with Paul
George for a lot of markets you can't
and you can't get anything Davis in free
agency Toronto Oklahoma City they
couldn't get those players if they were
free agents so they have to trade for
them and then sell them on their program
their organization the city and and and
you bleed to pay you more than anybody
else I you know in a lot of ways the
Lakers have shown great patience and and
maybe too much patience because you go
back two years they could have had Paul
George if they put the number two pick
in the draft and that would have been
Lonzo ball I don't know that Indiana
would have selected Long's at all but
hypothetically
Lonzo ball said that to pick or Brandon
Ingram would have got them Paul George
would you look back and do that now of
course you would yeah Kawhi Leonard last
summer you know they could have put
Brandon Ingram and and I don't think San
Antonio had a great interested ball but
there was a package they could have put
together to get them Kawhi Leonard do
you think who I would have left at free
agency once he was in LA he probably
wouldn't have so they have shown
patience holding on to those players but
there's no question they'll cash him in
for Anthony Davis that the ideal
scenario for the Lakers would be they
have the cap space to sign a max free
agent this summer I think what they'd
like to do is get a big free agent
sign him into their cap space then take
all those young players and a picker to
whatever it would take they
trade it for an Anthony Davis or another
big maybe if there's another star player
that's available but they've got to get
one of those stars in free agent and
free agency I'm not sure who they're the
front-runner for now so if they don't
get one this summer then they you know
there's gonna be great pressure for them
to get another star to pair with LeBron
and obviously there's none bigger out
there than then Davis and you know Danny
Ainge as good as he is is and they've
they've been in love I think with
Anthony Davis I don't think that's been
any great secret here what do you think
the Celtics are capable of doing because
I I look at Tatum is off limits but it
feels like you know they got picks Brown
Rozier smart feels like that they could
beef up a proposed trade there but what
kind of scenario do you see Boston
playing yeah they and Boston has shown
great restraint I mean look what they
gave up to get I mean look back what
they gave up to get Kyrie Irving they
didn't give up
they you know they didn't give up much
and they were able to do that now it'll
be different with Anthony Davis but yeah
they have targeted him listen everybody
the least targeted him I mean you know
everybody would love to have Anthony
Davis and I think for Boston you know
they've been you know they made calls
last season to New Orleans and Anthony
knew they did and and you know went in
and I talked to him about this last year
he went into the GM's office and said
hey I hear that they're calling about
trading form and he said yes tell them
told him yes they are no we're not
trading you there's no office they can
make that we would move you out but
you're right about Tatum and I think
that'll be a wild card I think mmm if
they were willing to put Tate him in a
deal that there's nothing the Lakers
could do there's nothing they could
Brandon Ingram lanza ball none of those
guys match up to to his potential and
production so far but I think any deal
Boston would do they would love to be
able to keep Tatum and and not move him
out but did you have any Davis he's 25
years old and so I think everything
would be on the table if he felt like
you know you had a chance chance to get
him but you know New Orleans right now
they're not in a deal mode with him and
you know remember he's got the rest of
this year and a whole nother year left
on his contract I was also curious your
take on this angle that I
with a couple of writers and that is
that LeBron is putting public pressure
on the front office with the Lakers hey
I'd love to play with Melo and I'd love
to have Anthony Davis it is he putting
public pressure on the front office to
do something well if you wanted Carmelo
Anthony he'd be on the team I mean they
had every chin Amin to eat listen it's
very hard to get hurt
it's a it's very hard to get yes any
Davis it's easy to get Carmelo Anthony
if you want Carmelo Anthony the Rockets
away them and your team will sign to a
minimum deal so the idea that he would
have to go public about Carmelo Anthony
I don't I don't buy it and I don't think
anybody else does in the league I don't
think he wants it hello I think he's
just doing a solid to say hey that's
your guy and I think that's where LeBron
is just saying hey I'd love to play with
him and leave it at that even though
we're saying well wait you're LeBron you
want him you can if you wanted to play
with him you know he'd be in layup line
with them right so when Anthony Davis
comes to down yeah that's yeah I mean so
I mean this isn't you know the Portland
GM knee little shake-up last year what
everyone's talking about Damian Lillard
did him going to the Lakers and Neal how
to quote publicly where he said hey this
isn't the Rucker League in New York
LeBron doesn't just get to pick the guys
he wants to come play with him we have
this thing the NBA called contracts and
Damian Lillard on the contract not going
to play he's not gonna be playing for
the Lakers and and I think sometimes we
forget that he doesn't just get to pick
the guys he wants you know this isn't
the all-star weekend thing right where
he's the captain and he's pulling guys
into the Lakers it doesn't exactly work
that way people in the league would like
it to work that way but it does it are
we gonna see maybe more beefed up offers
from the jeely to attract some of these
kids coming out of high school
yeah I saw rod Strickland here and
Allison Fisher who are leading that
program from the NBA where they're out
educating high school players and their
families about that option it's not
going to be a big number of players like
I know people it is $125,000 to elite
players to come in here and play but you
know
that is a significant amount of money
but the life in the G League is so
different than big-time college
basketball there's a lot of 6:00 a.m.
flights connecting through Midway in
Chicago to go play the Memphis hustle in
front of nobody I mean that's not the
same as playing at Duke Carolina and you
know packed arenas national TV
charter jets five-star hotels you know
there's actually girls on campus in
college you know you're just your today
is in in Iowa and so this isn't
glamorous this is it for an 18 or 19
year old kid this is not an optimum but
for players who feel urban you just
don't want this the academic part of it
get in a situation where they're not
eligible this becomes a viable option
but I I don't think they expect any more
than a handful or less in any given year
because they're not just handing these
out like you've got to be an elite
player to be tibialis before they got to
see you basically as a first-round level
pick watch safe travels thanks for
joining us as always we appreciate your
time thank you have a great holiday you
too Adrian will general ski has been
senior NBA insider for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]